the wall and the wall isn't like this
type of wall it's like a thin little
metal wall and you just hit it boom and
you hear the [ __ ] reverberating
and you hear him
and you hear the last eyes going like ah
ah like i'm saying and then he's dead
the next morning they put a yellow tape
in front of his [ __ ] cell
and
we went on about our day
how did they get away with [ __ ] like
this yo man in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
of course have a returning guest we got
the man himself china mac over here just
beating people's asses
[Laughter]
now you
we were just talking about this because
i was on um you know you know i'm always
watching your [ __ ] all the time right
and i see on youtube you calling out
somebody from no jumper which is [ __ ]
crazy like it's it's so interesting to
me when i see that [ __ ]
in a good way because i do appreciate
people be being called out for their
[ __ ]
right because a lot of the times it
doesn't happen now and usually it kind
of just stays online with just words
people just talk all wild and nothing
else happens and i think you know people
get really really comfortable with that
type of behavior
so like when i was like watching it i i
didn't get like the whole glimpse of
what happened but why don't you break
break it down for like what the [ __ ] was
happening since it was on your youtube
yeah so it's been a it's been a crazy uh
a couple days in la uh it's definitely
been kind of crazy
so basically about like you know get
them like a little closer a month
basically about a month ago
when i was out here last time um
i met uh i met a.d from no jumper
and um
you know we were talking and you know he
said he he messed with mac eats
and i'm like oh yeah i was like you
should come on my show you know like you
let's do something and he was like yeah
you know like um i uh i love food or
whatever so i started thinking about you
know what we could do and then i came up
you know i'm and i'm not saying that by
any means like i'm the first food show
guy or i'm the gatekeeper to the food
shows on youtube but it's something that
y'all discussed or i'm not
like you know the idea of rich like like
cheap food and expensive food like
that's not new i'm not claiming not to
be mom but if it's something we spoke
about
and something that you know
i said that hey we should do this
and then
you go next month and i you don't answer
my phone calls he didn't answer my text
he didn't answer my calls
um
he
and then i'm scrolling and i see that
you know he has a show like a food show
now and the food and his first show was
what what we talked about so i'm just
immediately i'm j i just felt
disrespected you know i'm saying i felt
i felt violated i felt cheated and i
could have just
i was trying to call them and text them
but you know i found out that i didn't
the number that i had wasn't the same
number or he changed numbers or
something like that
and
um um coincidentally
he the number he had in mind
i changed it too you know so um
so i guess he i was hitting him and he
was hitting me but i'm te i'm dm'ing him
too you know what i'm saying so
uh i didn't get no answer but then he
said that oh so let me finish i saw i'm
hitting him up and then um
i didn't get no response so i'm just
like he's this guy's ghosting me like
you know what i'm saying like and i felt
violated so it was i had two options i
had like whether
either i just don't say nothing and just
chalk it up you know what i'm saying
or
i
you know approach him whenever i see him
but then whenever i see him he's going
to be with people
and etcetera and his uh you know i mean
i don't think it would really work out
you know too much and so i was just like
let me just get it out the way now so i
just says i can't get a hold of you i
know how to get a hold of you i'ma just
talk on the internet you know and then i
spoke on the internet and he responded
immediately here i'm saying yeah yeah
and then you know i was like you know
what i mean you know i still feel some
certain way you ain't apologizing
nothing you saying you ain't do it so i
want to fight i i want to fade you know
what i'm saying and um you know it's
crazy as i met him in person right but i
just
it didn't really register in my mind
how big this [ __ ] god was this
guy's a big guy you know what i'm saying
like he's definitely like two of me
maybe two and a half of me like he's
taller than me by like you know he's
probably like six four six five god damn
i'm six one i'm not a small guy but i'm
six one but he's like
big like bouncer big yeah i mean
so
i once i'm standing like once i'm
walking up so i'm like damn you know how
when you start walking from afar you're
walking the building gets bigger and
bigger hold on bro like what is going on
did he grow
up my song let's play some mario
mushrooms and [ __ ] yeah
man and then um shout out to my god nam
uh from hollow tips he uh
he reached out to me and was like yo you
know like you know this this could get a
little tricky you know because he is
gang affiliated and all of that you know
what i'm saying so you know by you doing
that was kind of like you know that's
not how we handle things in l.a
so i was just like i well it's done
already you know what i'm saying so then
he was like but you're gonna have to
give him the fade i was like
[ __ ] it we could give him the fate i i
give it to him
you know i'm saying i feel like that
should i feel like that's what's needed
at this point at this particular point
you know what i'm saying because it's
like in my mind i feel like
if you let somebody disrespect you
you know other people are gonna he's
gonna talk about it other people he his
people will know about it and then
they're gonna talk about it and then
there's a close-knit circle of people so
everybody's
i'm saying it's a fight you know um and
so we agreed to do it and we did it
yesterday
and you squashed it everything's good
yeah we definitely squashed it uh you
know we came to the conclusion that it
was a misunderstanding or you know
whatever
i'm gonna just leave it like that you
know what i mean that's what it is we i
got what i had to get off of my chest
and i'm good with that now you know what
i'm saying
that's crazy man like it's funny because
like you know i was mentioning to you
before a lot of people don't function
like that where
you know uh words get said and then
there's no follow-through right right it
happens a lot now yeah it's it's very
very [ __ ] common right so especially
on youtube yeah a hundred percent you
know and um it's interesting though like
because i think you definitely had a lot
more to risk because you're not from
here right yeah like you have no
affiliations here at all whatsoever yeah
so that was a [ __ ] big risk yeah yeah
so for you like what made you
what made you still do it is it because
you already put it out then you just
didn't want that disrespect
yeah well i i mean i kind of like you
know
i i i
i knew that when i mean at least
in my mind
i figured it wouldn't get crazy you know
what i'm saying because
you know
i know people
he knows people it's not like he of
course knows more people out here than
me but i know some
some hitters out here too you know what
i'm saying so i know that
is mutual like you know i mean so i i
know i knew that it wouldn't really get
you know too crazy like crazy and i
don't have a game with me so we ain't
gotta you know what i'm saying it's just
you know so i figured that you know
um it was just something i felt like i
needed to do i mean not not for anything
else because nobody knew about it it
wasn't like
it was all broadcasted on the internet
or whatever but i just felt slighted i
felt like you know and i felt like
because for some whatever reason he he
felt like it was okay to do that to me
and i didn't feel like it was okay so
you know we gonna
we gonna do it like men you know i'm
saying and that's how i feel sometimes
you know we need to get respect and this
different type of respect you know what
i'm saying like you know
a respect from
in the streets is different than
respect like you know somewhere else
like an office or something you know
that's the hard part too i think when
sometimes people on youtube they forget
how different worlds can be right so
sometimes they'll place their opinions
on things of a situational world that
they don't [ __ ] know about right so
they'll say things like why would you do
that it's like because you don't
function in this world people function
differently right right like respect is
given
and taken away in different types of way
like it's not it's not your world right
so your opinion here wouldn't get me
anywhere right you know right yeah so
it's easy to be like oh that's so
childish you know what i'm saying
but um you know
that's your world that's
how you live in your bubble you know
what i'm saying but that's not what
happens where i live and where i where i
where i like you know spend my time and
do my business and you know
um
yeah
so
i just felt like it was something that i
i i wanted to do you know and we did it
and um
you know shout out to a.d shout out to
him you know like we shook hands
uh we had dinner after like me and nam
and all of us we went out and had some
dinner and it was just you know
sometimes yo listen people look at
fighting like
oh my god like that's the last thing
like you know but
yeah i'm gonna keep it real man some of
the people some of my the people that i
spoke i still speak to we had fights
with each other in the beginning like
you know me one of my closest friends
out here right now
you know i met him when he was my bunkie
and we had a fight and and when we was
in prison uh we was in the same cell
together he was like
he he like i was on the bottom bunk and
he took like i came back he took my
bottom bunk like you're not sleeping
down here no more you're sleeping i was
there first all of my stuff was there he
just moved all of my stuff to the top
and like was sleeping on the bottom
so i was and then he i was like yo
that's my bed and he
he said he looked at me
and um he was like it's my bed now and
he just turned his like he rolled over
like you ain't [ __ ] right yeah
right
i pulled his ass right out to bed like
i'm saying we started fighting you know
i mean right there you know what i mean
but he was again he was bigger than me
he was like you know so i guess he felt
like he could just do that you know what
i'm saying he beat me up you know he was
in the cell we couldn't really move and
[ __ ] so he i pulled him out the bed
started punching him but he got up and
then you know like i lost that fight but
you know i didn't lose the respect you
know i'm saying like i gained the
respect and we never moved out of that
bunk bed like we we stayed there after
that you know what i'm saying so it's
like you know um
and then we started respecting each
other like you know i lost that fight
but he he had a you know i mean he had
some too like he knew that i was gonna
fight you know what i'm saying so
um
you know i think that's the hard part
too when um
sometimes when i explain to like
listeners about like how you grow up
also predicates how you deal with
situations right right um
like if you if you guys kind of grew up
in any type of neighborhood where there
wasn't a lot of money it's kind of hood
as a little ghetto
usually what happens if somebody picks
on you they take your [ __ ] they're going
to continue to take from you constantly
right because you're an easy target
um
yeah you might get your ass beat if you
stand up or whatever what not but you
got to stand your ground at a certain
point right or it just happens over and
over and over again right and i used to
see that [ __ ] all the time growing up as
a kid right it's like some of these kids
like they would just let people
continually take from them right and
there's a certain point where you just
got to stand up for yourself and do some
[ __ ] i mean obviously with the nematica
machine somebody's got a gun to your
[ __ ] hand i don't suggest you you
know but i'm talking about situations
like that right it's like you guys can
scrap it out and see what happens and
even in this case too you might lose you
might win but you might gain some
respect i'm not saying it works in
everybody's world but you have to look
at it through a very specific lens and i
think sometimes it's hard for people who
haven't you know you know walked a mile
in your shoes right and they kind of see
that they go why don't you just let them
have the bottom bunk because this it
doesn't end there you know right like if
i let him have the bottom bunk then you
know what i'm saying next thing you know
him be [ __ ] washing his underwear and
[ __ ] like you know doing whatever the
[ __ ] like
nah you get like you can't you know
see this is the thing a lot of people
maybe a lot of people that's watching
this hasn't come from that like you know
environment right but sometimes that
environment bleeds into your environment
so then what do you do then right and um
so it's it's just better to like have
that kind of uh
skill set or like you know what would it
be skills or would it be have that type
of mind frame too
um within your thinking because
you know um and and this is something
that i wanted to talk about too like
it's something that you know us as
asians we don't we don't teach our
children that you know i'm saying we
don't we haven't been taught that like
you know the same thing we're talking
about sometimes you have to fight for
your respect you know what i'm saying
sometimes you know when somebody you
just there's certain things you just
can't allow somebody to do to you you
know what i'm saying it's not like we're
glorifying violence either we're talking
about like situational things right you
know and sometimes you have to stand up
for yourself sometimes and and and it
starts with
the parents it starts with the parents
teaching
um the kids that and we haven't been
taught that so
so our generation most of our generation
asian people in america has been like
you know has been taught not to do that
so it's it's important for us our
generation to teach our children hey not
not to behave like animals or anything
like that but you know when when you are
around some some wolves and some some
you you know you you know how to handle
yourself like you know what i'm saying i
i always tell it like this it's like
maybe not in if you guys you might be
thinking oh you're saying i should
always like throw a fist no it's called
like setting boundaries right and i
think a lot of the times two people
forget to set boundaries like hey this
is where i draw the line right you can't
step over this [ __ ] line yeah a lot
of a lot of people aren't a lot of
people feel like
they uh they're uncomfortable with them
you know what i'm saying but you're
gonna have to deal with that
uncomfortable
uncomfortability
or else you're gonna get more
uncomfortable like it's just gonna come
with more uncomfortability you know what
i'm saying versus just checking
something like you know in the beginning
you know what i'm saying kind of you
know a lot of times it doesn't even have
to get there you know what i'm saying
you just have to show that you're not
with it i mean we talked about the story
too on this podcast where you know there
was a guy who came in and
you know we're sparring with a bunch of
friends and we always go really light
very technical yeah your head might bop
back a little bit but
there's gonna be no teeth knocked out no
black eyes because it's very it's like
technical sparring
a guy comes in and my buddies talked
about this on the podcast too because
they never see me angry i don't get
angry like that like there's no point
like i'm a very jolly [ __ ] guy all
the time yeah and the guy comes in and
then we kind of we know we tap gloves
real light i'm throwing light and he
throws a haymaker on me bam and i just
see stars right and then after that i
just went red and i just beat the brakes
off this whole for the next like 20
minutes and everybody was telling me hey
we're good i was like no i'm not good
because he has to learn you can't just
[ __ ] do that to me because i already
know like he may not be doing it i'll
beat him for 20 minutes no for a good
for like 20 i wish it was 20 minutes 20
minutes
it was through the whole round i just
beat the brakes off this guy right and
it wasn't because i was trying to be
tough or anything else like that is that
i knew what his objective was it was i'm
gonna come in i'm gonna knock out this
youtuber i'm gonna make some content off
of this [ __ ] and then that was gonna be
his medal for the day but it's like
if i let him do that
i guarantee you there would have been a
clip recorded the next day and it would
have been posted up but you didn't see
any recording did you because he got his
ass beat right
he wasn't going to post that right and
you know this is like in terms of just
like the the
in this type of case is where i kind of
use an example of where i set the
boundary it's like you can't just do
that to me right like i'm a very nice
guy i'm very accommodating all that
other stuff but you can't
sock me in my [ __ ] face like that and
then you just walk away right somebody's
gonna get hurt even if i lose right i'm
okay with it right but at the end of the
day i have to set that boundary this
podcast is sponsored by better help my
lovely genius farts people don't always
realize that physical symptoms like
headaches teeth grinding and even
digestive issues can be indicators of
stress and let's not forget about doom
scrolling sleeping too little sleeping
too much under eating and overeating
stress shows up in all kinds of ways my
friends so here's your reminder to take
care of yourself and do less and maybe
try some therapy my friends therapy has
helped me so much and i'm going to keep
on harping about this because it's been
my savior i've tried focusing on my
physical health only and that didn't
work because my mental health was in
shambles and you know working with
better help has been a god said a better
help is customized online therapy people
and it offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's a lot more
affordable than in person therapy so
give it a try and see if online therapy
can help lower your stress genius brain
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com genius that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
genius right and it doesn't have to be
in this type of sense too it could be
when people are you know i don't know
like in a dinner situation somebody
starts talking all crazy you could take
them aside like hey you got to cut that
[ __ ] out right even that's a way of
setting boundaries without having to go
through violence but a lot of people are
scared to do that because it makes them
feel uncomfortable but it has to start
somewhere you have to have some bit of
self-respect to make sure that this
person understands who you are and i
think for a lot of young kids it's super
hard because i used to have trouble with
that too you know but the moment i
started setting boundaries is when
people understood like oh i can't really
push him over like that and it starts to
stop you know
right um
hell yeah
you you'll be surprised at how much
you know things can change
if you just you know set your boundaries
and that's what we need to teach our
kids you know we need to teach our youth
our children um how to do that and and
show them how to do that it's very
important because if you don't teach
them that then you're gonna really like
um handicap them
in the future if you know because you
would like to think okay i'm working
hard i'm gonna just keep my kid way out
of this but you never know with this kid
you don't know how the world is gonna be
when he comes of age or she comes of age
or you know uh and you don't know what
he or she is gonna get into or where
they're gonna go or what's gonna happen
right so you always wanna it's important
for us to uh
teach our children that because you know
everybody else teaches their children
that like you know all the other
nationalities and everybody else if
somebody puts their hand on you you you
know i'm saying like you don't let them
touch you don't let them invade your
space don't let them invade your
property like you know anybody you know
what i'm saying don't let people bully
you stuff like that like that's what i
always heard growing up
like when i was with other like
uh
cultures you know i'm saying other
people you know i would hear their
parents telling them that their uncle
was telling that teaching than that and
then i'm looking at me and telling me
that like so that's like how i got mine
you know but if i didn't have that if i
didn't go through whatever i went
through i wouldn't have that you know
what i'm saying yeah and i think to
sometimes people also confuse um you
setting boundaries as being rude it's
not it's not being rude it's letting
people know
how you want to be treated and respected
you know yeah but somebody else
disrespecting you is rude yeah right
exactly i'm saying like
i'd rather be rude than let somebody
else
like you know
be rude like you know disrespect me and
whatever like that's rude too so you
know it's important for us to like you
know make sure that because people see
that if you let somebody do it like you
said you let somebody do it one time
they gonna do it twice they're gonna do
it three times they're gonna they're
gonna keep on doing it until you make
them stop doing it and sometimes most
majority of times once they start doing
it you know you're gonna have to do
something more drastic to get them to
stop doing it yeah you know what i'm
saying versus if you just check it like
as soon as you feel and uncomfortable
like like somebody made you feel
uncomfortable you know what i mean i
don't i don't think you should just
immediately like just blurt out or do
whatever is on your mind but you should
definitely think about how you can just
set your boundaries yeah and address it
too like there's been plenty of
situations like that where you know
sometimes you got to take somebody aside
and even in your personal relationships
with like
like the woman or man that you're with
right like i have plenty of times where
my lady had to set a boundary on me and
i had to set a boundary on her like for
example here's an example too where we
could take it out of just like the
violent sense we were
this is years ago when we first started
dating and we didn't really know each
other and she was kind of talking all
crazy to me in front of guests right and
afterwards i took her aside i was like
hey you can get manage me as much as you
want you can't you can't speak to me
like that especially in front of other
people when we talk we keep our stuff
here other people can't do that so you
need to keep it here right and that's
setting a boundary it's not violent but
you kind of have to make sure that you
draw these lines and checks it's
uncomfortable now but what's what's
worse right it's something that [ __ ]
that grows out to be something crazy
right and a lot of the times too people
get mad at other people for continuing
to do this stuff to them when they never
set the boundary that's on you now right
you never told them like this is
unacceptable right you know
yeah yeah there's a lot of people that
just do things just to check
you know what i'm saying i listen i do
it too a lot of people do it like
they'll do something just to see what
your response is going to be you know
what i'm saying so okay oh you're going
to let that fly then here boom you know
what i'm saying oh you're going to let
that fly we in there you know what i'm
saying so now we could just do this yeah
you know because you said we could do it
you know i mean you didn't say you
didn't probably you didn't say tell me
you could do it but by your actions or
your or your non-reaction you told me
that
something you don't mind so yeah there
you go you see it on some [ __ ] like back
up or back in the day when people would
just like not pay the check when we go
out to eat they do it once they do it
again twice three times four nobody says
anything until somebody comes and it's
like hey you gotta make sure you pay
your food if not then you you know you
ain't gonna eat right but even something
small like that it's just very important
man i think a lot of people will learn
to be a lot happier with themselves
because when it gets to the point where
you let somebody constantly
push you to a corner and then you snap
you look like an idiot now right when
you could have just addressed it here in
a normal way right like hey
stop doing that [ __ ] [ __ ] you know and
then it would have never gotten to that
point right and so there's like a good
balance of like kind of being assertive
and not being angry and mean because i
don't want to get angry about [ __ ] you
know i want to just address it normally
and sometimes when you're being firm it
doesn't mean you're mad you're just
letting them know
this is where it stops right you got to
cut that [ __ ] out right yeah
cut that [ __ ] out yeah and for you
though i mean uh you know i've been kind
of following obviously i follow you on
instagram we dm each other all the time
but like uh your mom was you said her
cancer came back how's she doing now
um she's she's doing well uh
she looks happy chinese she looks real
happy she's so you know thank god um
when it was first reported it was um
breast cancer you know
uh and they said the breast cancer was
like you know
um
[Music]
was was i think it was stage three yeah
right that's what they said they used to
be
um but then
[Music]
you know the doctor said that they uh
said that they did another report
and saw that it was actually skin cancer
it was skin cancer but it went into the
breast
so it wasn't
it wasn't breast cancer going down it
was skin cancer going into the breast
which is a lot easier to do easier
because they can just remove the the
cancers right right so
so
that was like really
you know okay that was um
that was a
blessing yeah it was a blessing did they
remove it completely now and she's good
um yeah she's still going through her
her stuff but
it's uh you know i think she's in a
better space now that's crazy i mean
it's so dope too especially for you now
that you're you know you're not in jail
you can kind of
be with your mom through this right
because imagine how hard it would have
been if you had to do it through a jail
cell right you know yeah which i'm
pretty sure your mom's like super
appreciative she gets to see you and
then all this kind of stuff matters too
especially when somebody's trying to
heal to have their kid around right yeah
definitely
does that give you like like a really uh
dope perspective on like life like it's
like oh [ __ ] like i get to actually be
there for this time
yeah i mean it definitely you know i i
um
it's definitely something that you know
makes me feel better you know when i can
just drive her like if she oh you got a
doctor's appointment i'll drive you you
know like you know just take care of her
just show her that there's somebody else
there that cares
so yes it's it's very
it's it's rewarding you know because i
haven't had that chance before what was
your relationship like with your mom
like growing up were you always really
close to her see me and my mom is like
we have like we got a love and hate
relationship you know what i'm saying
i really resented her for a big part of
my life you know even though i loved her
she was she was involved in you know my
life
all the way but
you know she
she used to like as a kid she had me
very young she was like 17 18 when she
had me
and um she didn't she just came into the
country
she probably had me the year after like
she didn't speak english
she didn't have money and i'm saying so
she had me but um
she knew she was really rarely with me
she used to always just leave me here
leave me there
you know have me with my grandmother or
have me with my aunt but i used to be so
bad that nobody wanted to take me you
know so like you know i but i would do
it purposely you know because i know
when i'm bad my mom would come pick me
up so i would just do wow stuff like
i'll piss in your drawer
i'll do like wow yeah
like i'll break a window i'll just do
whatever right because i was just mad
like i just felt like you know like
i remember vividly my mom like dropping
me off
and then like you know i'm grabbing at
her leg like please don't leave me don't
leave me like you know i want to be with
my mother you know what i'm saying and
it felt like she just used to always
leave me you know and that like
um
you know i resented that you know i mean
and um
and uh yeah so me and her and then once
i got
a teenager like you know when she wanted
me to be more there i was like nah [ __ ]
that now like like you abandoned me yeah
it's over now like i'm [ __ ] i'm not
staying here like you know so
really really young like 16 i was out
the house like oh [ __ ] yeah i was always
out the house always running away you
know like because once i got
to the age where i had friends and i
kind of understood things a little bit
better i just didn't even want to be any
of my mom anymore because i felt like
she didn't want to she didn't it was
like me getting back you know what i'm
saying
and then um
uh uh
you know then i started going in and out
the prison like you know jail system and
stuff like that and
you know it was just my mom was always
there
but
um
you know i don't think we really healed
from that like from the beginning stuff
you know and i recently just looked at
that like damn that's something that i
need to address you know i'm saying well
i have the opportunity to
you know because that plays a part in my
like you know how i think right now like
you know that's that and then sometimes
i you know recently i looked at it like
damn um
you know mental health is something that
you know
we none of us really think that well i
grew up thinking like we don't need that
[ __ ] like that's what we're saying yeah
that's for weak people that's for crazy
people that's not for us even though i
went through mental health like in the
system but i never really took serious
and stuff you know i mean but um
recently i was talking to my friend
about you know the same thing about my
mom and stuff and they was just like yo
maybe that's something that you need to
like
you know speak to somebody about see
a professional about because you know
that's something that has
even i i kind of what i've learned what
what that did to me as a kid like with
what my mom leaving me and all this
stuff like you know um
that's still
that still affects me to this day but
i'm not to the point where i'm thinking
about that particular thing but what
that mean what that made me do in terms
of
like um
building this wall like you know
building this like just to be able to
deal with it and be able to handle it
what i started doing my defense
mechanism right
um that affects my relationships to this
day it affects how i deal with people it
affects what how i deal with my personal
relationships my friend
significance and you know all of that
stuff so it's something that i recently
said like you know that's something that
i need to uh
i need to address you know what i'm
saying wow you know i have the
opportunity to yeah so for you
do you feel like um
a lot of the
maybe like the relationship you have
with your mom does it also kind of seeps
into the way like specifically your
personal relationship with women too do
you feel like there's like an
abandonment issue with like girls that
you that you're with
my lovely genius farts thank you for
supporting our sponsors such as babble
because now i'm not out in these streets
doing dirty things because well guess
what your boy needs to pay check and i
love babble remember i don't sponsor
things that i don't like and i [ __ ] with
babble heavy for most of us learning a
second language in high school or
college wasn't exactly a high point in
our academic careers i remember when i
took spanish i tried learning it it was
not fun especially because the spanish
that i was learning wasn't applicable
when i was speaking it and listen i'm on
this journey to learn spanish and babble
has been there for me babel teaches
bite-sized language lessons that you'll
actually use in the real world that is
super important the stuff that you learn
in books in school is i mean look it
teaches you the language and the words
and stuff but it doesn't actually teach
you real world application and that's
the stuff that matters the most babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts with babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babel speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent because don't
you know people hate it when you don't
get the accent right what's the point of
learning the language when they don't
know what the hell you're saying right
now save up to 60 off your subscription
when you go to babel.com
gb that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
gb for up to 60 off your subscription
babel language for life
yeah like it's hard for me to connect
all the way you know what i'm saying
it's very hard for me because you get
that that defense up yeah you know like
once i get to that point i just
uh yeah shut down right yeah so that's
that's really been um
that's been something that
and and that on top of me being in
prison for all that time
like people leave all the time you know
what i'm saying like you know i had
plenty of girlfriends when i was locked
up and they just leave you know i mean
like you go and that hurts like you know
when somebody that you because when
you're in there you're in there you
don't have nothing and you look forward
to
like you know somebody that
still
sees you as a person somebody that still
you know
um cares about you somebody that still
like
you know is involved didn't like you're
not dead to them you know what i'm
saying oh [ __ ] and i think about that
and that's so important you know because
once you're in there you die
you know what i'm saying like you died
to people like you know what i'm saying
like people you people forget about you
you know your friends people that
every day that you see right now
whatever some people's gonna keep you in
in mind and write you and visit you and
do everything that you but there's gonna
be a lot of people majority of people is
just gonna you're gonna you're gonna be
dead to them like it's gonna be the same
thing as you you know
dying right because they'll just forget
about you and then when you pop oh my
god i missed you you know so much but
you know how much did you do that how
much did you really miss me so
that made me like just really
you know
it made me like
just not really get close to people yeah
there's a there's a trust issue there
right right especially too like i mean
the way you described not even think
about that like
kind of when you're in prison the idea
like your your humanity kind of gets
taken away right right so when you have
these people in your life who kind of
remind you that you're a human being
that you have feelings and these
emotions and you kind of open yourself
up to them and they bounce it's like
[ __ ] and then you do it again you get
[ __ ] over again and again and again
and eventually you just start to scab
over a little bit it's like oh i know
the situation because we're going to get
close i'ma probably say some important
[ __ ] to you and then when it gets too
weird or difficult for you you're going
to leave and so like a lot of like
defense mechanisms are like that even
for me you know
something that my parents used to do to
me when i was a kid and
we found out that was a trigger thing
for for for me was somebody who tells me
to do something without explaining it
what's something my parents used to do
me all the time just do it why and they
used to beat my ass if i asked why so
now if somebody asked me to do something
if i asked why and they just tell me
just do it if i immediately get angry
right and that's like you know trauma
that i have to deal with when i was
younger and it still affects me to this
day sometimes too i have to apologize to
my father because
he'll do stuff that's it's not even bad
but i'm so used to him calling me dumb
stupid and idiot you're useless when i
was younger right whenever he asked me
to do something the first thing i do is
get [ __ ] mad i try to pop off right
because i'm so accustomed to somebody
calling me dumb right you know and now i
have to like check myself it's like oh
he's not even doing anything right but
um you know when we get emotionally
scarred and we don't deal with these
emotions and it's kind of it's actually
really dope that you're kind of
unpacking this [ __ ] because most people
won't even do that they'll just be like
[ __ ] everybody else i know what i'm
doing and they'll just move on and
they'll continue to ruin their personal
relationships you know right
um
yeah it's something that i see like
that's happened and i'm just like okay
um
something's going on here you know what
i'm saying and um
you know it's just
it's just uh
it's it's important that when we see
something that we're doing wrong you
know that we we have to try our best to
check it or else it's just gonna
you know
it's it's it's gonna just keep on
happening you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then it's just gonna
you know it's not it's not gonna be good
you know so you haven't had this
conversation with your mom yet i haven't
what are you planning to have it
um
you know i plan on having it soon yeah
yeah i mean it's gonna be uh it's gonna
be some [ __ ] dude
i mean the hard part is is like i think
as we get older too
you know we also sometimes forget that
our parents were
kids and teens you know like your mom
had you when she was a teenager and i'm
pretty sure she still wanted to have her
teenage life
she wanted to
be young she wanted to do this but she
sometimes forgot that oh i brought this
kid into this world he's my
responsibility and so those things kind
of mix where they they have this
responsibility this child that they love
but they still want to keep their
independence as a kid themselves right
and so it's just you know the the
problem with that is that you have a
child that's collateral
you know and
your direct actions affect this kid
without even you thinking about it right
you're trying to live for yourself but
the moment you have a kid yeah you get
to live for yourself but you also have
to live with this child as well right
because what you do is going to dictate
how that kid is going to be in the
future you know i think a lot of parents
that's why i always say you know this
should be like an iq test
you know before you like have a baby
yeah
yeah yeah like there should be some type
of uh like a course or seminar or
something like you know i mean i mean
it's hard man like i always say to you
some of the best people in the world
aren't allowed to have kids but some of
the shittiest human beings pop out like
six or seven right it's the craziest
thing to me man yeah
right but um
yeah so
it's definitely something i plan on
working on soon with with my mom yeah i
mean yeah yeah yeah well did you did you
ever mention like what happened to your
pops is he still around
i don't know where he's at uh yeah i
haven't seen my pop since i was like
five
oh [ __ ] super young right so he breathed
on me too and i'm just like you know
what i trust his kids
as a kid that [ __ ] is like you know damn
man like my pops is gone he don't want
to be with me like and so it just feels
like damn nobody wants to be
like you know so [ __ ] it [ __ ] everybody
then you know that's how i started being
and i just started acting out
and it just made me just like you know
just keep on doing it and your mom was
so young she couldn't even see these
things like she didn't know what she
didn't understand yeah i didn't
understand she's just like oh this kid's
acting up but she probably didn't
understand one of the biggest reasons
like it's abandonment issues it's like
pops left and now you leave me over here
and you're leaving too like nobody
[ __ ] wants me right you know and when
you act up grandma doesn't want me
around either it's like i have nowhere
to [ __ ] go at this point you know
right yeah
so everybody watching man make sure you
uh
you know don't do that to your kids man
you might end up like my ass
it's hard man and you know being a
parent is so [ __ ] difficult like i
get scared to have a kid because i don't
i don't know if i'm going to be a good
parent you know hopefully i will be but
then the only thing i could hope is that
you know we become better parents than
our our last and we just kind of evolve
after you know
which is like the difficult part too
because i never i i like even now i
think about having a kid i feel like i'm
still a kid
so it's like i like to be responsible
for somebody else's well-being [ __ ]
scares the [ __ ] out of me bro like i
don't even know what the [ __ ] i'm doing
every day i wake up and i'm over here
walking trails and [ __ ] you know just
kicking bags and then next thing you
know i have a kid all that [ __ ] stops
scares the [ __ ] out of me man i think
you're ready
baby i don't i don't [ __ ] know that i
think you're ready i mean you know
sometimes you know
so sometimes you don't think you're
ready for something
uh
but
you know
you won't be ready until you're there
you know yeah yeah yeah um i think you'd
be fine i think you're you'll be a great
father you still doing music right now i
haven't been doing music i thought you
were you were you were you were doing
the track with uh [ __ ] uh cmac oh
baby let's get it on hood five five
five five creek
yo man um [ __ ] mac man
yeah so i did the song with him i
actually yeah that's like the
that's like the only song i've made in a
long time yeah oh [ __ ] was that dropping
uh the song is done i mean um i i want
to shoot a video for it while i'm here
so man that dude is one of the most
fascinating people i have never met
i
i can't stop watching his [ __ ] because
it's crazy to me how much he doesn't
slip up i'm waiting for him just to say
like
because he'll he'll say things in fives
all the time right
so he'll even if he's calling somebody
out right he'll be like you a [ __ ] you
a [ __ ] you a [ __ ] you a [ __ ]
you a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i'm
waiting for him to slip up but he always
hits the five and his vernacular is
always the same right like how often do
you have to do that to where you never
slip up
right he
that's where he's really smart at yeah
he has really good memory bro when i saw
this fool over here just [ __ ]
with the skid row and he's just coming
up to people like never commit suicide
everything's gonna see all right i'm
like yo this [ __ ] crazy brother
yo he is the illest man like i i i mess
with him you know what i mean because i
know you know
i know life dealt him some
some um crazy cards you know like and
i've life dealt me some crazy cards so i
see a lot of similarity with him and me
like certain things yeah i'm saying
that um
that
you know and of course nowhere near the
same but i do see certain things that he
went through that i went through and i
could relate to that you for me so
um i think he's i think he's a a
very
talented person a very entertaining
person when they come when it comes to
that he's just like he's entertaining
that dude was made for the internet
like he is made for the [ __ ] and i'm
telling you like it took me probably
about a couple of months to understand
what the [ __ ] he was saying because he
kept switching out words so i had to
pause and rewind i'm like what the [ __ ]
does that mean i didn't know what a sich
was for the lungs i was like what the
[ __ ] is a sich and i had to sit and
think for a second i'm like hold on a
second
it's [ __ ] yes i was like yo
this guy and so after all these stuff
started clicking i'm like oh now i'm
starting to understand his lingo a
little bit right and the only time i
heard him say b when he said bluetooth
he needs a dictionary
we need a [ __ ] mag dictionary hey you if
he launches uh yo c-mac if you're
listening to this [ __ ] if you launch a
[ __ ] mac dish dictionary that [ __ ] will
sell like hot kicks yeah let's make it
happen [ __ ] man that [ __ ] would
sell that [ __ ] out so fast and i think
what i like about him so much is he
really does have a hustler's mentality
he's non-stop he continues to create
content no matter [ __ ] what it is
doesn't really look back at what he
posts he just posts and he continues to
create no matter what and that's
something to be appreciated because
that's actually really [ __ ] hard
right you know but to be able to just
post and just go yeah i think sometimes
you have to like look back and like kind
of
you know see what's working and what's
not oh for sure but i think a lot of the
times like when it comes to creation we
get stuck on the creation part without
actually action so we have all these
like thoughts and ideas and then we
don't
you know put in the action then it goes
to waste you know him on the other hand
he has like even like a quarter of a
thought and it's just you know it's just
[ __ ] out there yo but that's how i am
too that's why i say there's a lot of
things that he does and i'm like yo man
like there's a lot of
this there's like a lot of similarities
like you know he he does a lot of things
i do type [ __ ] you know
like like like and it's crazy to me i'm
just like damn we're so different like
but um
yeah that's kind of like how i am too
like i just you know i just
you know that's how i was when i was
just putting stuff out putting stuff out
[ __ ] like you know and just really
not looking at the analytics and looking
at like you know
what how we can make it better you know
i mean you really kind of caught your
stride with mac eats like that's
something that um
i would definitely say is something that
most people can't do
because of
how you're plugged right right like
because you're so plugged into the
culture it allows for this this thing to
happen right like if i wanted to copy
what you did i wouldn't be able to do it
because i'm not plugged in like that you
know what i'm saying also too those
people in the videos make my ass sweat
like i guess you know i'm like oh [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying but because
that's something that you did really
really well when i saw you did mac eats
and you revamped it i'm like this is
your [ __ ] like because nobody else can
do this
it's just not possible somebody could
try but it would sound very disjointed
right and then and i feel like the
guests that you have on mac eats are
people who are on the fringe which
people don't really associate good food
with them right they just think that oh
these [ __ ] are just thugs what
the [ __ ] do they know right right but
you kind of give them you kind of
humanize them a little bit right which
is actually really [ __ ] dope right
you know thank you
like humanizing these people are where
you kind of get to
really get to see them shine right
because at the end of the day people are
people are people and most people don't
really care to look at somebody like
that and you you know what happens when
you break bread with somebody you really
get to see what they're about right you
know you know
yeah man i think um thank you for that i
think a lot of people
don't
um it's good
it's good to hear
like that when people realize that and
people see that people appreciate that
that's something i try to do you know i
mean and to be honest
it's something that i do
for
our asian people like i know a lot of
people
like a lot of asian people i don't know
i'm pretty sure a lot of asian people
watch my stuff but there's a lot of
asian people that don't watch my stuff
right because they're just like uh
i don't care about these people right
yeah but
the reason why i do it like that is
because
um
so many people say that asian people
don't care about nobody but
ourselves like you know we just don't
care about no other culture we don't
really care to
know about anybody's culture we don't
really
it's just if it doesn't benefit us or if
it doesn't involve us then we're just
like you know what i'm saying and i
think that's that is something that
through my travels and experience is
something that i learned how to do
really well it's the bridge right like
the bridge me to other
people
that come from different places and
share different backgrounds
and share you know different things and
find a way to bridge right and they
think that was like one of my talents
right
to survive
you know and um i saw that you know
our people really didn't do that you
know and you know it didn't really
you know it didn't really affect us
until now you know what i'm saying until
like you know things are changing
and you know now it's like okay um
well why should we care about what the
hell you guys are going through if
you don't even care about you guys not
even you guys don't even like
you guys don't even worry about what the
[ __ ] we're doing you guys don't even
have an interest in any of it so why
should we care about what you guys are
going through now you know and you know
to a point i agree you know what i'm
saying like if you got if if we're all
here and y'all next door don't care that
we don't have no electricity we don't
have no food we don't have water we
don't have nothing in this house because
we're going through whatever we're going
through and you know next door y'all
never stop to even care y'all never even
stop to look i just y'all know we got
these problems but y'all just not even
looking like
well too bad for them you know and just
act like it ain't even there okay that's
cool but then now once it starts
happening to you guys you know and you
guys need some help
why the [ __ ] should we care like yeah
and i think it's like a generational gap
too right because
there's there's like two parts to this
there's this idea like our older
generation right yeah they never really
cared to ask the neighbor what was going
on but they also never asked for help
right so it was it's hard right that's
why you see a lot of elder asian people
who get attacked they're not going to
the police because they're always scared
to cause trouble right and so for them
there was a language barrier there's a
culture barrier they don't understand
anything because the only reason why
they came to this country was to start a
better life as long as they have food on
the table and they're keeping their head
down they're working they don't worry
about governments they don't worry about
politics they don't worry about anything
they go as long as my kids are fed i had
this roof over my head i'm pretty much
good if i need help i won't even ask for
help i'll figure it out and i think
that's what a lot of these older asian
american people have but that was the
set foundation
of what people kind of view asian
americans as right but you know there's
a younger generation that's a little
different they're a little more plugged
in
right they they speak english they know
the language very well they understand
like american culture and so but because
of the i want to say the behavior per se
but the the older generation and how
they dealt with things it now bleeds
over to us right so when we have a
problem even though we were outspoken
about other people's causes they go well
your parents didn't care well those were
my parents you know this is me now like
i'm
here i'm plugged in like i'm here to
help out i'm here to speak out so if i
ask for help
it's hard sometimes too for people just
to do the right thing because it's the
right thing to do right because they
always need something else from it it's
like if i do this good thing are you
what are you going to do for me when
really if you are quote-unquote
inherently a good person you just do
things because it's the right thing to
do right and i think a lot of people
have this false sense of what a good
person is you'll see it you'll see it a
lot they go oh
you didn't help me so why should i
[ __ ] help you oh so you weren't
actually a good person you just did it
for the cloud you you liked how it made
you look as a human being you never
actually cared right you know and i've
been seeing that a lot lately and it
sucks you know right
right and um yeah so you know that's
that's that's why i started like you
know doing it mac eats the way like that
like kind of just
um
bridging you know i mean like showing
like
not look not showcasing the [ __ ] and
the
and the uh you know the attention
grabbing stuff like i go in these
neighborhoods i don't even ask them
about their gang affiliation or who got
shot or what happened here or who who
got killed here like you know i know
that if i did do that
that would make the ratings jump you
know what i'm saying but that's i'm not
here to
um i like that [ __ ] yeah i'm not here to
highlight that that's not what i want to
do what i want to do is highlight the
good right and kind of give
humanize it you know what i'm saying and
kind of let other people know about
these other cultures and there's it's
just not other cultures asian cultures
too because me growing up as a
chinese-american um i remember looking
at like you know like
our like the people the chinese people
that raised me and stuff like they
looked at vietnamese people like you
know what i mean
100 right like you know
they looked at like other people like
you know other people that comes from
different you know asian countries that
are a little you know a little
i don't know different you know like
like southeast asian countries right
yeah and um
and and you know i
so this is my opportunity to show
like to kind of bridge it like hey you
know i would like to know about your
culture i would like to know about your
food and i would like to show everybody
about it and you know that people love
me for that you know what i'm saying
people really
really love me for that like you know
what i'm saying and you know it's just
really a blessing for me to
be able to do that because
you know it's it's it's rewarding even
if it doesn't get all the views or even
if it doesn't get like a [ __ ] ton of you
know uh attention
it's just good to know that yes there's
people really out there messing with me
because
i cared enough to showcase them you know
what i'm saying to like you know to put
them on the map and
what i realized is people just want to
people just want to be
um
to be respected for what they do too to
be looked at like humans you know what
i'm saying to you know so
uh i really love what i'm doing with
maggie's i i really i really enjoy it i
think a lot of people enjoy it too and i
think in this like oversaturated market
with with like food videos you
definitely bring something in very
unique like once again there's not many
people that that's gonna be doing what
you're doing right like it's just
not because they're not gonna try to
copy it everybody tries to copy
everybody [ __ ] i mean how often is there
ever original content now right it's
just it's just there's a certain moving
piece that happens that moving piece is
you say wherever you go is probably
going to work out that way a lot better
and it's smart and i do appreciate the
fact that you're not asking them about
oh like who'd you kill oh where did you
guys what's the first time you ever
[ __ ] ran up on somebody and you
[ __ ] did a job because that's already
kind of feeding into this idea of what
people already know about them right
it's like let's share something let's
talk about the food and the culture
behind it right because
a lot of people don't know these human
beings and they kind of automatically
judge them right off the jump and i
think that's like it doesn't also allow
people to become better either because
if you only expect trash from this
person how do you think they're going to
behave right if you go this is all
you're going to be then why would they
ever try to shoot for something else
right you know yeah
right um
yeah i mean
it's it's uh so that's what i'll come
from that though
i could relate to that you know like i
could relate to that
and i want to just you know i want to
showcase that
and um
that's what we've been doing
with i'm really proud of that show mack
eats like it's mostly what's what's the
best thing you've eaten on the show
best thing i've eaten so let me tell you
i'm not a food critic like um people
will be like oh you need to
describe the food better and like you
need to you don't right so this is what
i'm saying like listen
i'm i'm not a
mark wiens or like whoever these other
like you know guys are that can do very
they describe food in a very eloquent
way you know what i mean they know all
the words and
they know you know all the stuff to
describe food i
don't give a [ __ ] right like you know i
i describe food how i want to describe
food and i you know if you want to
listen to somebody that's more eloquent
with their words and describing foods
and flavors then you know
um you could watch them but i do
something they can't do you know what
i'm saying so i like to focus on
what i do right and what i do is like
you know use food as a way
of breaking the ice you know what i'm
saying so my my show isn't particularly
all about food
the food is the is is the you know is
the shiny
thing you know what i'm saying that gets
people
interested you know what i'm saying but
it's really the stories and the
and the the culture behind the food so
you know um
my favorite food that i had
it's a few but
definitely one of them is in
cambridge
um cambridge when i went to go see my
bro millie's and he brought me to the
haitian community out there
the haitian food is fire is that the
first time you had haitian food first
time that should get spicy too bro
look at this guy
yeah yeah
look at this guy's face bro you're
traumatized man
your [ __ ] cheeks is red look at you
man i love something or something man we
went to holland ray's right and you guys
know if you've been watching me what
holland raises the pollen raised by the
way has some of the best fried chicken
ever and uh
but i know that she gets spicy
that she get real spicy right and i only
went up to like
i think hot and when i had the hot i
just had one bite and i was good
i shat my spirit out my [ __ ] dude
that whole day i thought i was gonna die
i was that bad i was suffering man i
ain't gonna lie
the next morning when i used the
bathroom i forgot all about what i ate
you know i mean it was early it was like
six seven in the morning i woke up use
the bathroom
sat my ass down and when that [ __ ] came
out
i was like whoa
what in the world is happening down
there that [ __ ] present treatment bro
that was burning it was burning it was
burning man you had the [ __ ] uh
howling
i know but what was for my mackey shows
you know i have a show i have an episode
of mac eats you definitely handle heat
better than i do i'm surprised you
[ __ ] actually ate that [ __ ] um
it well
i can't handle heat
i just don't really like to handle heat
you know what i'm saying why yeah
yeah i i like spicy food but
it's like you know it's good that i can
handle you know i mean anything past
what i can handle i could bear it you
know what i'm saying but what's the
point
why yeah well i'm not enjoying it you
know what i'm saying it's burning my
mouth it's burning my tongue i'm crying
my [ __ ] butt cheeks is clinching like
you know what i'm saying it's just not
fun i don't understand why like you guys
like that like some people love spot i
don't i don't get it either like i
i like spicy i like the taste of it you
know like like chilis and peppers and
stuff
but there was like this whole
psychological assessment of it it's like
people enjoy the pain and the burn and
that
that causes like a euphoric uh euphoric
thing to happened in your brain and so
people get addicted to that feeling
right and that causes them to enjoy
spicy food but i like spicy i like the
taste of like roasted chilies and
peppers like the heat is there but the
flavor is really [ __ ] good right it's
what you get in like that's why i like
like molcajete uh like roasted salsas
right so you have like the peppers but
they're roasted so they're very deep in
flavor it kind of brings out the
sweetness and the sugars and stuff like
that
i enjoy that but when i'm eating this
food and suddenly i'm like on the toilet
and i'm calling for buddha god vishnu
all these different deities
you know these [ __ ] i don't
even pray to allah you know i'm like
[ __ ] i'm doing something
save me dude
i'm not trying to have that [ __ ] right
some people love it i don't i don't
[ __ ] get it yeah i i think if you
can't taste the food and all you taste
as spicy is like
you know what is the point yeah yeah
yeah like you know that's why i love
sriracha sauce it's like it's a good
amount of heat it's a decent amount of
heat it's not that you ain't you're not
gonna be [ __ ] fireballs at the end
of the day you know what's your favorite
food then
i love
asian food
you know all types of asian food oh let
me let me ask you this i always ask
people this [ __ ] and i'm always so
curious so
you're on uh death row you got three
[ __ ] meals
breakfast lunch and dinner it does not
be one item per se
you know what i mean it could be a
spread what's your breakfast what's your
lunch what's your dinner i'm on death
row
that means i haven't had like any like
civilian food for a while right i think
i would go with
some cinnamon toast crunch
that's [ __ ] right
i'll go with some cinnamon toast crunch
all right
um i'll go with a nice smoothie of some
sort maybe you know peanut butter and
banana and
you know oatmeal and like stuff in it uh
i would definitely go with uh
maybe uh
a omelet you know like
avocado and mushrooms and the omelette
you
some some some wheat bread toast with
some butter
nah [ __ ] that scratch that you know
yeah you gonna die bro don't worry about
your figure like that [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] uh let's get it
let's get a bagel with some
peanut butter and jelly on it butter
like you know buttered with peanut
butter and jelly
and some you know
bananas and stuff in there
that for breakfast
all that
um lunch some some xiao long bao okay
okay
some shaolin bao from where uh
where is that bro you never had din tai
fung
i don't think so maybe damn
you've never had den thai fung bro
where is it yo
what are you leaving me feeling
comfortable right now okay
[Laughter]
is a michelin rated spot it's originally
from taiwan it started off at the small
shack
they built up the four or five story but
now it's an international brand you have
one uh in arcadia you have one all over
the world but then tai fung is michelin
rated the best xiaolongbao you'll ever
have
it like the the skin is so [ __ ] thin
and delicate mm-hmm then you have the
broth on the inside try that out bro
yeah what are you leaving yeah um i
leave sunday hey i'm gonna we're gonna
eat at din tai fung uh-huh and then i'm
a [ __ ] you're gonna this is gonna be
your standard for challenge okay all
right that so when i go on my um
death road trip i want some din tai
phong okay
um some shaolin powell i remember when i
was locked up i used to think about
xiaolongbao i used to be like wow for
real yeah like just a little stuff like
you know what i mean think about the
xiaomi bao i think about um
the the kanji with the with the with the
what is it the center of the egg
the century
with the with the with the with the what
is that the chinese donut
is that what it is
yeah yeah yeah the
in in cantonese you call it uh you know
or something like that but
that i thought about that a lot like i
don't know why i thought oh you know
what else i thought about um
the
preserved vegetables it was like the
little green oh the green preserved
vegetables i love that stuff you know
what else i thought about you know the
the rice roll with the it has that that
bread with the with the fried stick in
there oh
man yeah bring that to me i'll eat like
five of those oh man if you out in long
beach right there's a cambodian joint
called phnom penh
noodle bro they're [ __ ] porridge with
the with the century egg [ __ ] with the
fried doughnut oh they do that too in
cambodia yeah so cambodian food they had
that too cambodian porridge is [ __ ]
fire dude is it really it's hella good
you gotta try that yeah you gotta you
put on pen out in [ __ ] long beach
shout outs to them love that restaurant
food is [ __ ] delicious man they're
porridge
[ __ ] you guys send me send me that
send me the um you know the name i'll go
slide yeah man you gotta slide over
there
they know who the [ __ ] you are too so
like that that place is delicious man i
i go there all the time it's so [ __ ]
good yeah all right all right let's get
back to this death row thing so i think
a lunch
you know much
dinner you know definitely a steak you
know
medium rare okay
or like a cup of red wine okay you know
what i'm saying some um uh rasta pasta i
need some rice to pasta okay okay pasta
i know what rasta pasta is yeah i need
some rasta pasta with it you know what i
mean uh
and
for my dessert
i want me a cheesecake from juniors
but yeah man i think you know i'm a
simple man i think that that you can
send me off with that when you when you
were in jail did you always did you
think about food a lot like that i did
because man yo i saw this video of you
recently where you made this [ __ ]
prison ass meal
in the like you burned off the plastic
off of this kettle [ __ ] i was
what the [ __ ] was that i was mind blown
when you were when you were cooking the
meal with you with your homie yeah like
i didn't understand like how crazy that
[ __ ] was yeah like y'all literally
chef'd up a whole [ __ ] meal off of
this kettle yeah and a can yep i could
see i could see you there now
that shit's crazy i could see you like
shuffing it up like i could just i don't
know why but i could look in the cell
and see dave there like i was like hey
hey where are you how do you like yours
whatever you guys do protect me don't
[ __ ] me in the ass yeah and i'm cooking
i'll cook breakfast lunch and dinner
just don't [ __ ] me
up
your boy got hands but i'm soft
nah but um yeah like it was definitely
yo there's like
i've never seen some more creative
people than in prison you know because
with what how does the saying go with
disparity comes
ingenuity or something like that i'm
sure that sounds hella smart i don't
know what yeah but something like that
like when you don't got it you got to be
creative you know what i'm saying like
when you got it it's like you know it's
coming so i don't really got to you know
be too creative but what's like a common
like uh
like like all around every prison person
makes like food
bread what's that
so that's basically like um you take
yourself a bag of chips
maybe you know hot cheetos devitos
whatever get a big bag of chips crunch
it up you know
crunch it all up until it's like flaky
like you know like it's just dust
right and then
you put like you take um you take some
cheese like couple slices of cheese you
rip it up
put it drop it in there with it and then
you take some noodles some ramen noodles
you crunch that up
and then you put some ramen noodles in
it
and then you like put you know whatever
meat you have maybe a summer sausage or
where do you get all this stuff like you
get it from commissary okay so they in
common like in prison they sell you
stuff but they sell you all like
[ __ ] garbage like snacks and
chips and
like you know all preserved stuff like
you know stuff with preservatives and
[ __ ] and um you could get every prison i
was in you could get cans and you know i
mean tuna fish and like you know jack
mac cans fish and all that stuff in
prison not in jail not not in like
county jail so in county jail is a
spread so you you put the you put the uh
noodles in there then you put like a
beef stick what i used to do is i take
the beef stick split it right take a
razor split it
and then you make it like flat
and then you take some matches and you
burn the beef stick
with the matches and then all the you
know
it it turns into like a little like
like charcoal like chocolate like a char
flavor like a charred like you know beef
stick
delicious and then you know you just
blow my phone and then you just rip up
little pieces and you put it in this bag
of chips with cheese and all the other
stuff right
when you put some hot water in it it has
to be burning hot water like like like
190
and then you put it like you know you
put enough in it and then you just wrap
it up
and then you just let it sit and it
turns into a brick
you know it'll be all condensed and all
of that stuff would be condensed and
then you just bust open the bag and you
have like a brick
a
disgusting looking brick
let me ask yourself do you make that
[ __ ] now for fun
i made it like a couple weeks ago
i actually have the taste for that [ __ ]
sometimes man really just want to eat it
like bro you and it's so bad for you
like it's just bad this is so bad but
like is it because like is it because
the prison food is so bad you guys just
you guys have to be smart and just make
some [ __ ] yeah you gotta you know they
feed you like dogs in there you know i
mean what are they what yeah i'm
actually actually don't know like what
are they what do you eat if it's not
stuff that you're making like what do
they serve you um
they feed you like dogs oh this is nasty
stuff like yakisobi
oh yeah yeah it's not i mean i've seen
yakuzobi in like a japanese restaurant
but it's nothing like that it's just
slop
you know what i'm saying and then they
hungarian goulash
and it's just like slop it's just all
slime
that's the best word way to describe
prison food it's slop
jesus so that's i see now i understand
like why you you're talking about how
your humanity is taken away right like
you're giving dog food it's like this is
what it is right you're just gonna eat
this or you die
yeah it is what it is god damn so that's
what the spread what what was that what
was the meal that you made with the
homie in the video oh we made some dirty
rice which consists of like calamari and
and and instant rice you take the like
the uncle ben's rice
you put all that stuff in it calamaris
and then you put like you know seasoning
and your oysters and stuff and then you
just
you know cook it up it's really good i
mean i wouldn't eat it now but you know
you know when you would you know it was
your head yeah like now once i made it
i'm just like you know okay i want to
eat it now but in there that's like
delicious
delicious
like five course
you know just you know that [ __ ] blows
my mind how creative people get you know
when i watch that video that should put
me into a rabbit hole of just people in
prison making [ __ ] right and i'm like
dude girls be making somehow they get
eyeliner out of like glue and [ __ ] and
burning stuff i'm like no you've seen a
different [ __ ] like that i never even i
never you know more about that stuff
than me because i've never been to a pr
a women's prison yeah when i was
watching like the women's presence stuff
like they were they somehow burn some
other [ __ ] with some other stuff with
like light bulb stuff and they somehow
make eyeliner mascara so if they can
gain some of their femininity back right
and i'm like who the [ __ ] figure that
out like who i want to know the person
that figured that [ __ ] out like and it
became a standard right because somebody
had to make that spread to make it a
standard in the prison for everybody
right some who was the [ __ ] that
was like okay we're gonna crush this
[ __ ] up put hot water and make a [ __ ]
garbage bag burrito and but then whoever
whoever invented it is like it traveled
throughout all the prisons all the
prisons
which is crazy they need they need to
make a a story about that guy who is
that that that'd be [ __ ] actually
kind of funny
i want to meet this brother i'm the one
who made this [ __ ] yeah this is dookie
laga food this is dookie yeah we're
trying to eat some [ __ ] dookie chips
right now
that's just wild y'all you know what
jackson wang is yeah yeah yeah i made
one for him oh for reals it's on that
yeah i could watch it that pretty
[ __ ] dude that's so pretty yeah
he's going to prison he's getting [ __ ]
for sure yeah instantly yeah
they walk at him they're going to
whistle at him like hey i haven't seen
[ __ ] walk through this [ __ ] place
and alone that's crazy
i love jackson though jack's super dope
yeah he is like we dm every now and then
like he's a super dope dude yeah i mean
i made him a uh
a prison spread
damn that's funny did he like it
he said he liked it he loved well i
don't know if that was just him saying
that he liked it but yeah he loved it
really
damn dude like i'm always so curious
about that stuff because when you're
like
because it's all carbs too so he was
like on a carb diet like he hadn't had
carbs in so long oh that [ __ ] was
delicious yeah it was just he didn't
give a [ __ ] right it was good when i
look at his skin i'm like bro dude that
shit's pure as [ __ ] bro he looks like
snow right that full is one beautiful
[Laughter]
[Music]
a dude of asian dudes to be pretty like
that and [ __ ] i'm like damn dog you go
to prison you [ __ ] lunch meat dude
yeah yeah
yeah the cops might get you before
[Laughter]
was it hard dealing with cops in prison
um were they pretty chill
nah
i would never say they were chill they
they're definitely on some [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying
um it's just
rikers island like the cops are like
corrupt as hell i think the cops are
corrupt i mean the police i mean the
police the uh officers correctional
officers
they'd be they'd be like
you know they gotta enforce
so they'd be on some [ __ ] man like
you know i just
yeah yeah i had some bad experiences
with them i had a buddy who um
he was doing like some street race and
[ __ ] and then he was put into a cell and
some [ __ ] he scrapped with his friend or
whatever what not but either way he had
he had beef with another dude um when he
was like street racing and [ __ ] and they
put him in the same cell you know with a
bunch of everybody else and they're like
just in jail and
you know obviously you're gonna be in a
small space what's gonna happen they
started scrapping so they separated them
out
and my dude was like mouthing off to
whatever like the the the jail guard or
the ceo there
and
they're just like all right cool so
apparently i didn't know
that if you don't get to see a judge
before all this [ __ ] happens they send
you straight to rikers he's on new york
and so they he specifically wouldn't let
him see a judge wow because he was
mouthing off to him and then he he
didn't know yeah yeah they're going to
play all the time they will lose you in
there man yeah
well when i was coming up you know i
think it was like more towards it was
changing once i got up there but
they were killing
like people like and you know people
that didn't have any family members or
whatever they would just like
beat them to death and then nobody would
even like check for them like type stuff
it was
kind of goddamn really like that yo bro
though it was it was like it was kind of
it was scary like i it's crazy to me how
i don't even think about this stuff no
more i don't think about prison at all i
don't think about
the
the [ __ ] that happened but when i do
think about it it's like damn that [ __ ]
was some horrifying [ __ ] like
like it was some horrifying [ __ ] like
some [ __ ] that i was just like what the
[ __ ]
but you know
i just somehow i was able to just like
forget that [ __ ] what's some of the
craziest [ __ ] that happened
um
some crazy stuff well you know well
personally or what i've seen well i've
seen some wow [ __ ] man like you know i i
so one of the things when i went to
attica prison like
you know
that prison was notorious
for uh
the police brutality in there they
didn't have cameras in there and um
the officers ruled with our iron
club like you know they they're on it
you know i'm saying as soon as you get
off the bus they tell you
listen we don't give a [ __ ] what you do
to each other you guys can kill each
other you uh we don't give a [ __ ] we you
guys once you guys get in the yard
go ahead you know what i'm saying but if
you touch one of our police officers if
you touch one of our officers you're
going to die
you're going to die that's it you know
what i'm saying and
i was like what the [ __ ] like
all right like [ __ ] [ __ ] just [ __ ] me
then
like alright yeah
so you know it was just and then the way
that they ran their prison it was just
like
when you walked there there could be a
thousand people
walking the hallway maybe not a thousand
like let's say 300 people walking from
like the block to the yard right and
it's 300 people on this line and then
300 people on this line so
like this right and you won't you could
hear a pin drop all you hear is the feet
and then all you hear is the sticks boom
boom two knocks that's straight stop or
you know what i'm saying
three knocks is like turn and that's all
you hear and if you even make a sound
they are gonna one they're gonna pull
you over they're gonna let everybody
walk out they're gonna put you on a wall
right and then once everybody once all
the lines go throughout the door your
you will be standing there on a wall
with like [ __ ] 15 gigan ass
like officers like big bear looking
[ __ ] like dudes that been
upstate and never left the jungle like
the mountains and [ __ ] like they even
eat goat milk like they grew up on goat
milk that makes them big
grizzly [ __ ] yeah giants like
and they just standing behind you and
they're just like you know
they'll they'll put you on a wall
they'll say hands on a wall
and and then they'll put you spread your
feet but they'll spread your feet far so
it's like you know what i'm saying and
then if you even go like this that's it
once you turn your head that's it
they're gonna [ __ ] you right they're
gonna yeah i've seen so many people die
like that like just like getting beat by
the police officers and they don't make
it back to the south i've seen that
several times you know what i mean i've
seen officers
i hurt like my neighbor like the person
that was next to me
he didn't speak english and rikers
island and the officer that like we had
a riot in the house right this person
didn't have anything to do with it you
know what i'm saying but we had a riot
in the house and finally when the
officers was able to
subdue everybody and get everybody in
the cell they were going into these
cells and like like telling people to
search them right so that the the guy
who spoke spanish he was just like
what and like i'm saying that the
officer is telling he didn't say he
didn't move or respond or they went in
there beat him to death like you heard
boom like like like like swinging for
his head missing and hitting the
the wall and the wall isn't like this
type of war it's like a thin little
metal wall and you just hit it boom and
you hear the [ __ ] reverberating
and you hear him ah
and you hear the last eyes going like ah
ah like him saying and then he's dead
the next morning they put a yellow tape
in front of his [ __ ] cell
and
we went on about our day
how did they get away with [ __ ] like
this yo man
you know
oh
they just were like oh he was in like a
gang fight and
that's the end of the story right i mean
of course they do investigations and
people you know
you know whatever but yeah that they for
that now i they change the prison system
a lot it's a lot
the officers can't do that no more like
like that they put
um cameras everywhere and stuff so it's
harder for them to do that but for a
good amount of time that's what they
were doing they were they was just like
you know abusing their power how the
[ __ ] do you like mentally deal with that
[ __ ] i couldn't even imagine
like i can't even imagine
trying to compartmentalize hearing
somebody get murdered by people who are
supposed to be the upstanding citizen
right because they're the ones that are
supposed to be good people quote-unquote
yeah but they've they'd be having more
issues than us like yeah i'm saying yeah
they'd be having issues they they come
in and take their issues out on us you
know what i'm saying and i guess it's
crazy because you know
like
we did that on the street like you know
we have our issues or whatever and then
we take it out on you know whoever we
robbed or whoever we stole from wherever
we and then we go to jail and then the
officers
in turn you know take out their their
[ __ ] on us like they get paid to do it
though and they get paid to do it you
know so they they uh you know if they
have issues at home wife their kids or
whatever their wife is sleeping with the
mailman or whoever their best friend
they come in there and
they unload that on us you know what i'm
saying and um
yeah that was that was my reality for a
little bit yeah that is [ __ ]
frightening man all right i can't i
can't deal i can't deal with that [ __ ] i
i wouldn't want you to it's not
something that you should deal with
that's [ __ ] insane man because you
know we've we've like we had the
conversation people were like what would
you do in prison i'd kill myself i can't
survive that i don't think you would
kill yourself though you you definitely
you would definitely find it cause you
know what i said i said when they when
they gave me 10 when they gave me 10
years i was like what
what am i going to do with my life yeah
like 10 years
like of your best years yeah i'm like
i'm
it's over yeah but i was 19 saying that
like you know yeah yeah yeah you know
but you dude once once
once i got to the third fourth fifth
year it was just like
all right you know this is what it is
and you know
you just come like
you just become like you know
um numb to it you know and then time
just starts going by
yeah man that's crazy next thing you
know you're making [ __ ] trash bag
burritos and [ __ ] trash bag burritos
that's crazy you know what i'm saying
that's [ __ ] wild man like it's kind
of crazy to see how much you've like
taken this experience and you know
transform your life because a lot of
people don't do that they become
institutionalized like this is a part of
the a chapter of their life that never
ends
they go in they go out they go back in
they go in and i've you know personal
friends of mine like you know we you
know in korean call me young's
they're still doing the same [ __ ] and
i'll hear i don't i'm not really
connected with them anymore because i
can't be cause they're still doing dirt
you know but
they're saying like yeah he just went
back into prison you'll be out in a
couple of years it's like [ __ ] and
they're like you know 38 39 40 and
they're still doing the same [ __ ]
because they're so it's almost like that
jail cell and that lifestyle becomes
their comfort yeah that was me for a
long time like you know glad it was me
like younger like because be crazy if i
still had that issue now but when i was
younger like i just couldn't stay i
couldn't stay out
you know like i'll come home
be home for three months five months get
locked back up doing some dumb [ __ ] uh
come home for
for a long time a year was my longest
time that i was home
and i would just always just keep on
going back back back
like where is he now back so you know i
could definitely understand that and i'm
so glad that
you know it's not like that no more you
know i mean i i don't want to go back
you know
um
and because it was like i was watching
like i was seeing all these old people
coming in with new numbers how about how
long you got five years 10 years
15 years oh i just came home from doing
20 years he was home for six months and
now you got another 15 years [ __ ] and
i'm just like man
no
yeah i can't do that man like i just i
can't i can't envision myself dying in
there you know what's the thing that you
enjoy the most you know being out of
prison like what's the thing that you
kind of appreciate about your freedom
the most
sex
let's go baby
[ __ ] yeah
yeah i didn't know if i could say i
didn't want to you know but yeah that
he said whatever the [ __ ] you want this
goddamn podcast
let's go
that's funny yeah but
that's definitely one of the things that
i miss the most you know of course you
know
you know my family being with my mom
stuff like that but
[ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
you know that's the other thing that i'm
thinking about is like how the [ __ ] are
all these dudes in prison and you guys
can't get [ __ ] for that long that [ __ ]
yeah bro it's it's it's really a
deciding factor for you for me man like
i've never
like yeah i'd never die hell no because
it's just you know i like sex too much
for me not to have it no i'll tell you
this if i'm in prison for 10 years and i
get [ __ ] once dude i'm crying like i'm
literally crying as we're [ __ ] like
just like just balling
it's it's it's bad and then i it's also
like people like you know
um they make like makeshift [ __ ] the
[ __ ] fees and [ __ ] yeah fifi's in in
new york we call them susie's oh my god
yeah doug i saw see this is the thing
too like i've never been to prison but
you know all the homies tell me about
the [ __ ] yeah this guy has an
infatuation with that [ __ ] he'd be
studying you watch it all actually
i love like my my habit that i have and
this is why i have a random like
just this textbook dictionary of
knowledge is like if something interests
me for a second
i'm reading about it down to the t you
know what i mean and i have like this
random like knowledge about [ __ ] because
i'm so [ __ ] curious about stuff and
so like just that that too like it's
weird like the different names or
something and i want to know it's like
how the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] what do we do
the documentary on the fifi guy who the
[ __ ] is this guy who's the fifi guy yeah
the fifi guy and the [ __ ] dukey
burrito dude need to have a conversation
on one table and like how did you do
this like how'd you do this that's funny
that's just [ __ ] wild to me man see
these guys don't go to jail no you need
[ __ ]
and jail is so bad like it's just not
worth it like you know it sometimes
something is worth it yeah i'm saying
like you know
some things would be worth it for me but
a lot of things most of things just not
worth it like you know just
they just strip you of your humanity
they strip you of your like
your you know strip you
of being a human really really do
because the first thing they do is they
strip you
butt ass naked
and then they you know you gotta [ __ ]
turn around and spread your ass cheeks
for another man
you gotta cough and you got to do that
like a lot though like every time you go
on a visit
like you gotta when you get on
there yeah yeah you gotta strap your
pants and turn around and spread your
like bend over and spread so you have
another man i've never seen my [ __ ]
before have you ever seen an [ __ ] no
right i've never i don't know what my
[ __ ] is i'm not flexible enough but
another man has seen my [ __ ] before
and like another random person has seen
my eyes a bunch of them actually i just
don't it's always made me uncomfortable
like yeah i don't think i could ever
just that's probably the most scary
thing about prison is like somebody's
just digging into my ass it's like hold
on a second bro if i if i knew a ceo
that always [ __ ] with me and he was
gonna check my ass i ain't wiping i'm
like you about to see everything here we
go let's go dude
i'm dead
he's gonna hate me he's like yup i saved
this fresh ass dookie for you enjoy
[ __ ]
i would [ __ ] hate him
[Laughter]
i can't deal with that [ __ ] man oh
before we end this podcast man like what
are you working on like what's your
what's your next [ __ ] um
oh uh well the thing that i really
wanted to talk about here was uh the
petition that we started
for um citizen app oh yeah yeah yeah
uh
asian languages
on their app and if you don't know what
citizen app is it's the app that tells
you what's happening within your
community in real time
so um
a lot of a lot of the the mate so
citizen app is in
um 60 major cities
10 million users so it's already up and
running but they don't have
it available in asian languages only in
english and spanish so what happens is
like say somebody say you're in new york
city or you're in san francisco or
wherever the hell you're at and uh
somebody is on the street um
attacking somebody or or just not even
attacking anybody just like you know
harassing people right somebody's gonna
put it like upload it and then incident
happening here boom and then you'll see
it right so now if you see somebody
doing some crazy stuff
right um you know our grandmothers or
anybody if you know of course they would
have to learn how to use it and stuff
like that
um
if it was accessible for them
in their language then they would be
able to see like okay
maybe it's not time for me to travel
right now now it's time now it's not the
time for me i'm not gonna go outside i'm
not gonna go to the train station i'm
not gonna go shopping right now i'm just
gonna stay inside uh and that's so
important because it's in real time you
know our people
like asian people like you know our
grandmothers and mothers and you know
people that can't read or speak english
um
they gotta depend on the news to find
out what's going on you know in their
community and the english news is first
but they're not gonna report it until
like at least an hour two hours later
and the chinese korean and everybody all
the other news is ain't gonna report it
until like five hours later so you have
a window period of all of this time that
these people in this area are not even
gonna know what's going on right down
their block so for instance this is
brooklyn shooting right in
in in brooklyn and let's just say the
dude was shooting she shot the train and
he's walking around you know
shooting people picking people off if
that app now now let's say there's a
grandmother that's coming down she's
getting dressed putting on her jacket
you know and getting ready to go to the
train station right she's walking out
and she walks down so let's just say she
walks the direction of the shooter boom
you know what i'm saying that's game
over now if she had the app
you know and it reported oh boom what
does this say
shooting
in this vicinity oh it's right here
close the door i'm not going outside and
then until it's over you know what i'm
saying and that's a useful tool it's
very very important tool that yeah i i
think like all older asian people too
they kind of like trust the system a
little too much you know they think that
they walk outside you know this is
america there's cops i should be safe
and it's oh it's changing yeah
yeah it's changing yeah so they need to
you know be a little bit
you know a little more street smart
about that [ __ ] you know especially
because like you know i feel like
specifically in new york when i'm when i
see like chinatown right they think oh
you know everybody's chinese here you
know and they kind of had their guard
down because there's an area they grew
up in for the past 50 60 years you know
but the area is different now right you
know there's [ __ ] crazy people
there's a bunch of crackheads walking
around a bunch of psychopaths right and
you know the neighborhood that they grew
up in it's not the same it's not the
same so it's it's so we have a petition
to get um
asian languages onto the citizen app so
we're trying to get citizen app is you
know and it boggles my mind
if they did their their entire staff not
their entire staff but there's the
majority of their engineers are asian
right
they're asian you know they're chinese
they're korean they're whatever right
and
the language isn't on there so you know
i had spoken to them like about a year
ago
and they said you know they would they
would look in they you know they would
work on it but a year after they're
they're still not on there but it's
because nobody's
nobody they're picking up about it
nobody's speaking up about it right so
if you have an app that's useful for the
people it needs to be available
especially with all of this stuff that's
happening it should be fair it should be
available for us too you know so um
especially large populations that of us
in these cities um
so yeah we started a petition you could
find a petition
on um it's change.org
you could just put a
citizen language or you can um click the
link in my bio on my instagram at china
mac
um yeah that's what i got going on
that's very important so if you
you know if if if if you ever thought
about hey what can i do like what what
can i do to help it's things like this
you know i'm saying like you know this
this could help and
one step at a time so everybody go sign
that petition and let's let's get
citizen to uh
to to to listen to us you know
and also what else am i working on um
mac eats i've been on mac eats i got a
bunch of episodes coming out
uh and you know that's about it you know
just creating content and working on my
book i've been writing a book you know
oh [ __ ] that's gonna be an interesting
ass book that's for sure god damn right
yeah so i've been working on that really
hard i'm like about 75 done with it so
yeah that's my that's my um that's what
i got going on man that's dope man well
you could check
all your socials is china mac right yeah
chinamac uh
my youtube is chinamactv so those are my
two major like two where i really go so
y'all could check me out on chinamac tv
on youtube and chinamac on instagram
okay well check them out there
geniusbrains every sundays at 12pm uh
and we'll see you all next time man give
them a follow and then uh make sure that
you guys go ahead and sign that petition
for the citizen app it's super important
if you guys want to see what you can do
for your community or just people in
general hit that link and then you'll
see in the description below see y'all
next time peace let's get it